or with a brexit deal in the headlines
and now today's Revelations about those
Hancock WhatsApp messages plenty on the
agenda for prime minister's questions
which is coming up in around quarter of
an hour at midday I'm joined here in the
studio by labors James Murray who's the
shadow Financial secretary to the
treasury the conservative MP Dr Kieran
Mullen and also Sarah Olney who's the
lib Dems treasury spokesperson and mp uh
in Richmond Park as well good to see you
all thank you so much for coming in uh
Kieran let's start with you talking for
the government first of all uh I think
British is like probably you know been
enormously looking forward to prime
minister's questions they said he's had
a pretty good week but now these Matt
Hancock WhatsApp messages how damaging
do you think these are well I think as
you said uh I think even the prime
minister's harsh as critics will say
that what it's achieved this week is a
really fantastic achievement for all of
the United Kingdom and for Europe at a
time where we you know we need to be
unified we need to be standing up to to
Putin and I hope and expect that
there'll be a focus on those issues
um I I think they're particularly the
change in trade Arrangements is
something that many people said he
wasn't going to be able to get
change to the treaty tax again many
people said he wasn't going to be able
to get and he's achieved that and more
so you know I hope that there's a some
coverage of that and that should be in
there deserves to be in terms of Hancock
I've not seen the the details of those
messages and oh it's all over the papers
yeah well a busy morning I'm afraid and
I'm rushing to get here on time so I
haven't seen that but I think the
important thing what the public would
expect is that there's a proper proper
review of what went on during the
pandemic and that's going to be achieved
through the inquiry and so I think that
will look at things in the round I I
know myself I volunteered on the front
line during the the pandemic I I know
the difficulties that we face in terms
of looking after patients in hospital
and where they went next there was a lot
of talk at the time which about there's
discharges into Care Homes and and the
evidence since then hasn't really
reflected the rhetoric particularly
heard from the labor party about the
impact on that the evidence suggests
actually Hospital discharges when you
study actually what went on in Care
Homes played a relatively minor role in
in the spread of covert you have to
remember people come in and out of Care
Homes all the time stuff include but
that could be what this is showing if
Matt Hancock was saying well let's test
everyone from hospitals but not people
from the community and it was the people
from a community bringing in the covert
I think what it shows is these are
complex issues and I was never
comfortable at the time that the labor
party weaponizing it as in a way to
attack the government for their record
on coverage when we really didn't
understand what was happening as I said
the evidence has shown not just in
relation to the care home discharges but
but covert deaths overall which again
geared storm at the time saying we had
the worst record in Europe and we were
cautioning you know you really can't say
that the evidence isn't there and again
since then when it's been studied
properly by academics our record is
pretty decent and pretty comparable to
most of Europe so I just would caution
about looking at individual experts and
not studying it properly which is what
the inquiry will do let's bring in James
Murray I mean you're being accused of
weaponizing covid but but when you see
the the revelations that we've had from
the former Health secretary this morning
I mean do you think it is right that we
all pause and wait for the covert
inquiry or do you think that this tells
us something we didn't know well look I
think what it reminds us is how much
people need the inquiry to bring the
truth out into the public you know the
bereaved families need Justice I think
more widely right across the country we
need accountability we need to
understand what went wrong now obviously
you know some of these reports in the
media today are very concerning and
about the decisions that were taken and
it reminds us you know that those
decisions taken had such devastating
impacts on people particularly people in
Care Homes you know really important
decisions were taken then but I think as
I said this reminds us of the importance
of getting on with that inquiry and
through delivering that Justice to
debris families and the lessons for all
of us that we need so what are your
thoughts be I mean we I spoke to one of
the lawyers for three families a short
time ago and she said you know she's
spoken to quite a few of them this
morning they're really angry well it's
going to be I think a very distressing I
don't know a few days few weeks who
knows how long it's going to take for
all these Revelations to come out and uh
you know they're going to be confronted
with the evidence of what was going on
behind the scenes that's going to be
really really difficult for them I think
you know we really want to see the
covert inquiry uh you know really get to
grips with all of these issues and and
study all of the evidence
dispassionately and come up with a
proper analysis of what happened and
some recommendations to the Future and
that would be the right way to proceed I
think some of the sensationalist
releasing of WhatsApp messages it's
going to be really hard for the families
and uh you know I hope
I I hope that you know that the media
treats some of this responsibly I think
we do have a right to know exactly what
was going on behind the scenes but we
have a right to know so we can get it
right next time and that's that's really
where we should be uh focusing our
attention and that's what the inquiry
has been set up to do and uh Kieran
Mullen lady Hallett whose Chairman's
inquiry has said today that this is not
going to go on for years uh it is going
to come to its conclusions as swiftly as
possible I mean did you think it should
be expedited the inquiry is the only way
of doing that I think it's appropriate
for lady Hallett to decide the the
timetable I'm glad that she seems to
understand that that uh sure sure it's
possible is is it going to be desired by
everybody I don't think anyone wants it
to extend but I don't think it would be
for me to say exactly what that looks
like lady Alice the one that's going to
see the volume of evidence and get an
idea of how they're going to go through
looking at it all it would be fair I
think okay
um well we did talk about a little bit
about what's happened this week in
politics and and with the Windsor
framework James Murray and has what she
seen achieved the near impossible here
with this with this agreement but we've
been really clear that if a deal is in
the National interest it was in the
interest of people across the UK and the
interests of people in Northern Ireland
we will back that deal to get it through
you know the Prime Minister needs but
the country first and so particularly if
he's having any difficulty with his back
benches we said on the labor benches we
will support this deal getting through
because it needs to be in place you know
people in Northern Ireland have had
months of uncertainty businesses have
suffered from that uncertainty as well
and there's been a lot of collateral
damage to our wider relationship with
the EU trying to you know improve
relations with the European Union in the
meanwhile so as I said this deal if it
needs labor support to get through the
House of Commons when it comes to road
we say We'll back it but are you not
supporting it slightly dude teeth
because if this is a success the success
that it seems to be this will very much
improve where she's your next chances at
the next election which is obviously
something that Kirsten will be
particularly pleased about well like a
lot of this is trying to clear up some
of the mess that was created by the
government that Rishi sunak has served
in and I think when I knock on doors
across the country what people say is
look these guys have had 13 years in
power what have they got to show for
that they've run out of energy run out
of ideas and you know we think it's time
for a general election well I think I
would just say that what mess do you
think we would have been in if James and
his party had got his way the last
election we'd have a second referendum
goodness knows how that would have
turned out so whatever challenges we we
had to get through in terms of moving
Parliament forward which she absolutely
did we would be a lot worse off if
you've got your way and we'd have been
debating the whole thing all over again
and Sarah you know all the other parties
are determined to drag this out further
we took the country forward we got
Parliament working again if we had to
revisit elements of that deal to get it
you know even better which is what we
have done and that was the right thing
to do Sarah you're shaking your head
well only I think what we've seen this
week you know Rishi sunak celebrates you
know the changes he's made to the deal
just points up what a terrible deal it
was in the first place and continues to
be for businesses for fishermen for
Farmers right across the UK you know
this government this conservative
government have erected all these
barriers to trade and I'm speaking to
businesses in my community all the time
about the impact that the difficulties
in importing and exporting is having on
their ability to make a living I you
know and it's kind of like the you know
Rishi sunak has literally acknowledged
this week that it was a bad deal and he
and all of his conservative colleagues
including you stood on an election
promise in 2019 that this was a great
deal the best that was possible and and
that's just been proved not to be true
preference would have been for us in the
middle of a cover pandemic having to
deal with an ongoing deadlock in
Parliament with a second referendum it
was not a covert pandemic in 2019. no we
would have been in 2020 still debating
these issues and deciding about a
referendum when the fandom hit us Boris
Johnson knew it was a poor deals
feel a good way it just doesn't stack up
with the facts I you know we've we've
understood that when the protocol was
introduced there was already the
understanding it may need to be
Revisited and of course the biggest
issue with the protocol has been that
the eu's unwillingness to act reasonably
when it comes to checking Goods that
cross the border and they've moved on
that so as per usual you know the focus
is on us instead of the focus being
across the Channel with their
unwillingness to act reasonably we've
managed to get them there over the line
but you know I just cannot you would
have had us carrying all this stuff on
for another year another 18 months the
difference that's been made is that
Rishi sunak has approached the
negotiations in good faith and with a
willingness to get it done and that was
completely lacking with Boris Johnson
with Lord Frost we've just seen so much
rhetoric from the conservative
government in the past and look at all
the damage that it's caused and and what
listen to you both is a real reminder of
How Deep The divisions between brexit
were and are still for so many people uh
Sarah Vaughn in the mail today James
says that it's time for the a country to
heal it's time for the country to move
on from this do you think that's right
well I think there is a sense that
actually reopening some of the brexit
discussions as we've seen on the other
side of the table actually does bring a
lot of that division back up and what
we're saying is look brexit is done from
the labor price point of view questions
around you know single Market customers
Union they are history we're not going
back there what we need to do now is
make brexit work and that's what our
focus should be on
has joined us in the studio Beth
um the Prime Minister certainly I I
would I would say thinks he's had a good
week he's you know is he coming into
prime minister's questions to collect as
medals too well it might be Jane the
first prime minister's questions in a
while that Rishi sunup might be almost
looking forward to in the sense that he
has pulled off its seams this brexit
deal a new deal if you like in which
elements of the protocol have been
adapted and a new conciliatory era if
you like between the UK and the EU at
number 10 are absolutely delighted that
this has landed in a way where there
hasn't been descent yes the dup are
still looking at it but this is being
banked as a win let's see the dup
haven't given its blessing yet but I
think from a labor perspective they will
want to focus on what one person
described to me is the issues affecting
people uh right across the United
Kingdom at the moment and that again is
energy bills because we saw this week
um that the cap will be lifted in April
and that means effectively that people
could end up paying another thousand
pounds uh for energy the average
household uh so I think there will be
questions about uh what the prime
minister is doing will they uh postpone
lifting the cap in April will they push
that out to the summer and I think what
kirstama will do is try and yes allow
Rishi sunak to bank his win but then
quite quickly move it on to other
subjectives on the issue of Matt Hancock
and these WhatsApp messages I'm sure
that there will be a question in all of
that from kirstarma about the families
that lost loved ones the covert inquiry
and the government's culpability in that
and I'm sure he will ask a question
about that today and if he doesn't
there's the Urgent question coming up at
12 30 from labor as well so will the
prime minister is prime minister obliged
to stay and get involved in that or do
you think he will just go he's not
obliged to say and get it get involved
in that but there will be this uq on the
issue about discharging people into Care
Homes this was
throughout the covid era if you like and
then in the aftermath of it questions
about people untested going into Care
Homes and the way in which that spiked
the pandemic the way in which that
caused the the loss of life has been a
running question of the government and
the hope is that the covert inquiry
finally settles the matter on the issue
about the telegraph Matt Hancock said
today that the story is wrong and that
is not what happened and that this is
partial information being released and I
think the inquiry will hopefully look at
all of the information in the round and
give the public answers that perhaps
they can trust before we let our panel
go just back to the The Windsor
framework agreement and James Murray for
labor I mean you slightly touched on it
will you be relieved if this is the end
in adverted Commerce of brexit and in
the end and the chewing and Frames well
I think for people of Northern Ireland I
want certainty on this businesses in
Northern Ireland want certainty on this
and people across the UK want to move
Beyond this this roadblock we've had in
terms of negotiations with the EU if
this gives us an opportunity to do that
we will support it because it will be in
the National interest and Sarah what are
your thoughts if this does mean perhaps
the end of of the constant discussion
about it's not going to be the end I
mean really this is just the the next
development you know obviously as Beth
says we need to see what the dup say and
then it'll be the actual implementation
and all you know how how does that
actually play out but also uh if we have
now got to the place where we've got
more positive relationships with uh the
EU and I think that's really something
really very good that's come out of it
what more can we do to improve the deal
for everywhere else in the UK because
there are still significant issues that
people are dealing with every day and
just
[Applause]
just picking up on that as well I mean
the ABR has forecast that the UK economy
will be four percent smaller than it
would have been before brexit in the
long run now I asked Jeremy Hunt about
this he said I don't agree with the
figures with the forecast but regardless
of where the forecast lands there are
questions I think this deal is open this
up about how the government can improve
trading relations for the whole of the
UK in order to help grow the economy at
a time when we are heading into or in
recession I think I think the the
challenge with Russia and Ukraine I
think has finally got the year to
realize that we are and will always be
one of their friends and that
cooperation and working together with us
was always possible and always going to
be in everybody's best interest and I
think we've all hopefully got to a point
where we can get them to stick to that
and agree with that and most of the
issues were from the EU not being
willing to compromise because they felt
they were going to lose face whatever it
might be but in the end they've been
seen this in their interests I think I
think but I think prime minister is on
his feature gentlemen and ladies we're
going to pause it there Mr Speaker this
morning I had meetings with ministerial
colleagues and others in addition to my
duties in this house I shall have
further such meetings later today
it matters thank you Mr Speaker the
Prime Minister understands the
importance of NHS stuff because he was
out there every Thursday night clapping
for them during the pandemic he was
therefore also surely know that he
hasn't got a hope of dealing with the
NHS crisis if he doesn't invest in its
Workforce we have a plan to double
medical places and ends the Scandal and
the scandal of straight A students being
denied the chance to become a doctor
patients
supports our plan even his Chancellor
supports our plan why doesn't he
[Applause]
know which anybody needs to keep up we
are doing a Workforce plan
they're tens of thousands more doctors
more nurses in the NHS record number of
GPS record investment in the NHS that's
what you get with a conservative
government delivering
everybody
[Music]
Mr Speaker will the Prime Minister join
me in congratulating the staff of
Nottingham University Hospitals trust
who faced with a challenging winter with
300 kobit and flu patients as well as
thousands of whole appointments affected
by industrial action who have succeeded
in reducing the backlog of those
awaiting more than 18 months for surgery
buy it a quarter in just a month and
we'll be further reaffirm the
government's commitment to the
Redevelopment of the Queen's Medical
Center in City hospitals are the second
biggest Hospital investment program in
the country
well I joined my honorable friend in
thanking everyone at Nottingham
University Hospitals trust for their
fantastic work and I can confirm that we
are committed to a new hospital scheme
at Queen's Medical Center and City
Hospital as part of our new hospital
program I know that progress is being
made and I look forward to seeing the
project come to completion we now come
to the leading the opposition
thank you Mr Speaker and can I join the
Prime Minister and wishing everybody a
happy Saint David's day Mr Speaker after
13 years of Tory failure the average
family in Britain will be poorer than
the average family in Poland by 2013.
that's a shocking State of Affairs
if the tour is limped on in government
we're going to see a generation of young
people learning to say I'll be the same
pet in Polish aren't we
[Applause]
listen
Mr Speaker it's clear to everyone that
the biggest impact on household's living
standards is the energy prices that
we're suffering at the moment as a
result of an illegal war in Ukraine and
I'll just remind The Honorable gentleman
what we are doing to ease people through
that because of our energy price
guarantee right now the government is
paying over half of a typical household
Energy bill saving households right now
a thousand pounds it is one of the most
generous support schemes globally now he
knows he knows future decisions to
support cost of living for the budget
but if he's concerned about the cost of
living what he should do is stop making
inflationary unfunded spending
commitments
and back our plan to halve inflation
[Applause]
the dictionary definition of unfunded
commitments is last year's Kamikaze
budget
as the speaker
the only country in the G7 still poorer
than it was before the pandemic and he
stands there pretending it's all fine
total denial about the damage and
decline that he is presiding over
delivering growth and tackling the cost
of living crisis will mean standing up
to vested interests energy bills energy
bills are going to go up by 900 pounds
in April he knows he's going to have to
act but who's going to pay hard-working
families through higher taxes are more
borrowing or the oil and gas giants
celebrating record profit
[Music]
to visit Davos recently Perhaps Perhaps
Perhaps Perhaps while he was there
perhaps sir he missed the survey of 4
000 Global CEOs from a hundred different
countries that ranked the United Kingdom
as their number one European investment
investor
now
vested interest in the unions and back
our minimum service level
there's only one party with a plan for
growth but if this party here
there's only one party that broke the
economy and they're sitting there
they're on energy bills it's not as
complicated as he pretends oil and gas
companies are making vast unexpected
profits whilst working people face
misery of higher bills he can boast all
the items but companies like shell
didn't pay a penny in Windfall tax last
year and they're still not paying their
fair share now why doesn't he admit his
mistake get rid of the loopholes in his
botched windfall tax and finally choose
family finances over oil profit
chance line
tax on Energy company any energy
companies
and energy companies will pay a 75 tax
rate on extraordinary profits comparable
indeed higher than other naughty Nations
now that's what his shadow leveling up
secretary called for recently but I've
got good news to them we did it a year
ago
you know I know Mr Speaker they clip
they claim to support leveling up but
they really do need to keep up
this summer he introduced the tax on
seller they haven't paid a penny
fantastic work
if he was serious about investing in the
future of the country he'd start with
housing a few months ago his back
benches forced him to scrap house
building targets at the time he stood
there and said it would mean they would
build more homes
well would you believe it a few months
later the home builders Federation say
house building is going to fall to its
lowest level in 75 years now he can
change course on this he can bring back
targets and planning reforms or he
conduct that fight and let a generation
down which is it
[Applause]
speaker we've had recordly high numbers
of household
of his government but he talks about
investing for the long term of our
country and if that's important when it
comes to energy security Mr Speaker but
Labor's policy Labor's policy is to
oppose
new or gas licenses in the North Sea it
is an absurd policy that would see us
paying billions to countries abroad for
our energy while shipping it here with
twice the carbon emissions its typical
political posturing it's bad for the
economy it's bad for all security just
like the labor party
hey
what
because of the noise I don't think the
prime minister's hearing the questions
because I do think it was on host
building
[Applause]
at all all the house
on house building Mr Speaker that's the
lowest level for 75 years a whole
generation of people desperate to get on
the housing ladder 13 years in power and
all he's got to say to them is it's
somebody else's fault let me deflect no
wonder they're furious with his
government and it's not just bills or
housing families are paying over a
thousand pounds a month just to send
their child to Nursery if he scrapped
his non-dom status he could start to
fund better Child Care put money back in
people's pockets and get parents back to
work seems a pretty simple choice to me
so what's he gonna choose wealthy tax
avoiders or hard-working parents
Mrs Mr Speaker if we want to see what
happens with house bearing under a labor
government just look what's going on in
London Mr Speaker
well but and when it comes to facts the
facts don't suit his argument let's just
go over them the wealthiest pay more tax
the poorest pay less tax than under any
year of the last Labor government Mr
Speaker
now about his plans he's already spent
he's already spent the money he's
claimed he'd raised from that policy on
five different things Mr Speaker it's
the same old labor party always running
out of other people's money
[Applause]
Mr Speaker he's never happier though
he's pretending everything's fine or
blaming someone else and didn't we just
see it there he is choosing tax
supporters over hard-working parents
Mr Speaker I don't want to finish this
session without asking about the covert
disclosures in today's Daily Telegraph
now we don't know the truth of what
happened yet there are too many messages
and too many unknowns over families
across the country families across the
country will look at this and the site
of politicians writing books portraying
themselves as heroes or selectively
leaking messages will be insulting a
ghoulish spectacle for them
but the heart of this is every family
who made enormous sacrifices for the
good of the country or who tragically
lost loved ones
the country deserves better the covered
inquiry has already cost of taxpayer 85
million pounds and hasn't heard from a
single government Minister yet so can
the Prime Minister assure the house no
more delays that the inquiry will have
whatever support it needs to report by
the end of this year
[Applause]
well
Mr Speaker the last couple of years were
an incredibly difficult one for everyone
involved in the Health Service and I pay
tribute to all their hard work and I
know the house will join me in that
regard and now rather than comment on
piecemeal bits of information I'm sure
governor general agreed me the right way
for these things to be looked at is the
covert inquiry that's why we've
established the covert inquiry and he
will know he will know as I have he has
mentioned it one or two times before
that he was a lawyer in a previous life
that there is a proper process to these
things it is an independent inquiry it
has the resources it needs it has the
powers it needs and what we should all
do in this house is let them get on and
do their job
foreign
ly welcome the prime minister's work to
resolve the Rubik's cube of the Northern
Ireland protocol
it's open s the prospect for resuming
more positive relations with our nearest
neighbors last week Imperial College
generously hosted an event to celebrate
25 years of environmental audit
committee's scrutiny work academics from
Imperial and the other world-class
universities that support our work have
been clamoring to re-engage with their
research Partners through Horizon and
other programs can my right honorable
friend assure the house that he is has
commenced negotiations to resume an
association for the UK with Horizon
Europe hi Minister well I thank my right
honorable friend for his support for the
Windsor framework he's right about the
benefits that it can bring and also join
him in paying tribute to our incredible
research Community who do a fantastic
job
um again or assure my writable friend
that we will continue to work with the
EU in a range of areas not just research
collaboration but also strengthening our
sanctions against Russia energy security
and crucially a legal migration I look
forward to those discussions and hope we
can conclude them productively on a
range of different areas without come to
SNP leader Stephen Flynn yeah
here Mr Speaker yesterday the yesterday
the Prime Minister said that EU single
Market access was special exciting and
attractive if that's the case why is he
denying it to the rest of us
[Music]
well Mr Speaker it's Mr Speaker it's
disappointing that The Honorable it's
disappointing The Honorable gentleman
is seeking to play politics with a
situation in Northern Ireland Northern
Ireland as he well knows has a unique
place in the United Kingdom and what we
are trying to do is restore the balance
inherent in the Belfast Good Friday
agreement and he would do well to
acknowledge that
Stephen Flynn Mr Speaker let's be clear
what the Prime Minister said yesterday
was the EU single Market access will be
a good thing for business now of course
that's in contrast the leader of the
labor party who said in December the EU
single Market access would not boost
economic growth does it hurt the prime
minister to know that the labor party
believe in brexit more than he does
[Music]
Mr Speaker
with regard to Northern Ireland the
important thing to note is to avoid a
land border on the island of Ireland
between North and South that is what is
crucial to achieve in getting the right
framework for their Arrangements in
Northern Ireland and the businesses
there that trade across that border on a
daily basis with complex Supply chains
need and value that access that is
something that the Windsor framework has
sought to achieve and I believe delivers
it it's not it's not about the macro
issue of membership of the European
Union it's about getting the right
mechanisms in place to support
businesses and communities in Northern
Ireland and I would say Donovan
gentleman he knows better than that he
knows that this is about Northern
Ireland and I hope that he can support
what we've agreed continue across
[Applause]
[Music]
me was excited to see the First new
nuclear reactor for a UK power station
in more than three decades arrive at
Hinckley sea this week will the Prime
Minister make it his personal mission to
deliver vital new nuclear power at
Wilbur in my constituency of honest
morne one of the best nuclear sites in
the UK
[Applause]
when it comes to our energy policy the
important thing is to focus on our
long-term energy security that means
more Renewables more offshore wind
hydrogen ccs and indeed more nuclear
wilfer remains one of the best nuclear
sites in the UK and the strong support
from the local community and indeed my
honorable friend makes an attractive
site for the UK's nuclear Revival and I
know great nuclear British nuclear when
that body is up and running we'll be
taking a very close look at it all the
Beachwood well I have to say Mr Speaker
it's great to hear the conversion that
the Prime Minister has had on the
benefits of the single Market
[Music]
it's uh access to the Geo Market both
markets and the benefits that that
brings uh will his government commit to
investing in infrastructure and higher
education provision to maximize that
balance wow
well thank you Mr Big I thank my
honorable friend for his engagement and
support in developing The Windsor
framework and I think it delivers on
what he wanted which is to ensure that
we do protect Northern Ireland's
businesses and the supply chains that
they have and I can give them that
commitment he and I both want to see
more investment in Northern Ireland not
just from the government but also from
the private sector this agreement will
unlock that Investment Group critically
a step on that journey is to have a
reformed executive something that I know
everyone in this house would like to see
sir Oliver Hill it's my right honorable
friend agree that in these difficult
times the Free World must stand together
and with that in in mind would he also
agree that strengthening our friendships
and support with other countries in
Europe is important will he welcome the
delegation here today from Lithuania and
does he agree with me that the decision
to hold the head of states of NATO
meeting uh in in Lithuania in Vilnius in
July shows what a strong they are and
also how important we think it is to
strengthen the Eastern flank
[Applause]
a minute no I I agree with my right
honorable friend I'm delighted that
Lithuania around the city of Vilnius
will host the NATO leaders Summit in
July and the UK does have a strong and
growing relationship with Lithuania it
was just yesterday that their defense
minister was here supporting our efforts
together with them to train Ukrainian
soldiers and at the summit we will work
together to ensure we can deter and
defend against Russian aggression by
making sure that we implement the next
phase of the most radical military
transformation since the 1960s Sarah
Chuck
to date 79 people have been killed on
Smart motorways last January the
government said it would pause their
role out the Prime Minister said smart
motorways are unpopular because they are
unsafe we need to listen to drivers and
stop with the pursuit of policies that
go against common sense
since then three new schemes have gone
live with three more expected shortly
prime minister especially during a cost
of living crisis how do you justify
pushing ahead with these death trap
roads prime minister well Mr Speaker
safety on our roads is our absolute
priority and we will do everything we
can to make sure drivers do feel safe
last year we in fact paused the rollout
of smart wet motorways not already in
construction while we consider the data
in next steps and in the meantime we've
committed almost 900 million pounds for
safety improvements across the entire
network
zero carbon Guildford won national
recognition here in Parliament receiving
the climate coalition's Innovative UK
Community project award they've taken
what is often an overwhelming subject
and turned it into local issues with
tangible solutions to give people agency
well my right honorable friend join me
in congratulating all the volunteers
including Ben Izzy and Mark on the award
and does he agree that Grassroots
organizations like zero carbon Guildford
are key stakeholders in our national
journey to achieve Net Zero yeah prime
minister I joined my honorable friend in
congratulating zero carbon Guildford for
receiving the climate coalition's
Innovative UK Community project award
she's absolutely right that Community
empowerment engagement and action can
play a role in supporting the UK's
transition to Net Zero enabling
communities to access the benefits that
it brings from Greener jobs to improved
Health Smith thank you
last week I met with asean nurses and
one of the biggest challenges that they
face is the crumbling buildings of the
royal Lancaster Infirmary Hospital
bosses will promise Capital funding as
part of one of these so-called 40 new
hospitals back in January but it's March
and they haven't seen a penny so how
many broken hospitals and broken
promises will it take for the prime
minister to finally fix something
well Mr Speaker we're investing record
sums record sums in the hospital Capital
upgrade program across the country I'm
very happy to make sure that we're
making progress on the scheme that she
mentioned and then shortly gets the
detail of that but not just the 40
hospitals but 90 upgrades around the
country and up to 300 Community
diagnostic Centers and electrical
surgical hubs this is a government that
is backing the NHS with the resources it
needs great Tracy you uh Mr Speaker the
tragic death of more than 50 people over
the weekend when their small boat broke
up off the coast of Italy is a sad
reminder of the total disregard for life
that the illegal traffickers who
facilitate these Crossings have in order
to make their money so can the Prime
Minister set out what steps he's taken
to bring an end to this barbaric trade
and also to reassure my constituents
that stopping illegal immigration
remains a key priority for this
government
prime minister my uh my honorable friend
is right that the tragic incident near
Italy at the weekend demonstrates how to
well illegal Crossings put lives at risk
that's why last year the Home Secretary
and I announced five new measures to
tackle the problem of small boats
Crossings including the largest ever
boats deal with France and a landmark
deal with Albania but we must do more
and as soon as the legislation is ready
will it will be brought to this house to
ensure that if you arrive in this
country illegally you will not be able
to stay you will be swiftly detained and
removed to your own country or a safe
Third Country alternative that is the
right and responsible way to tackle this
problem
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker the Prime Minister
and I have one thing in common
we've both had to step in and sort out
legal and constitutional matters sorted
out by her created by his predecessor
but one the right honorable member for
Oxbridge
now the Prime Minister has boasted that
his new brexit deal puts Northern
Ireland in an unbelievably special
position because it will have access to
both the UK and the EU markets and he
said that this makes it the world's most
exciting economic zone
so my question for the prime minister is
this
if there can be a very very special
status for the province of Northern
Ireland why can't there be a very very
special status for the nation of
Scotland
well Mr Speaker there is a very special
status for the nation of Scotland and
that's inside our United Kingdom
[Applause]
Betsy cadwallada University Health Board
was yet again put in special measures
the chairman and the whole board
resigned on mass as they no longer have
faith in the Welsh labor government yet
on a call earlier this week the Welsh
Health Minister told me that it wasn't
Welsh labor government's fault that
Healthcare has collapsed in North Wales
now given that labor run the NHS in
North Wales kind of suggest to the
people of North Wales whose fault it is
and who should put it right
well Mr Speaker I share my honorable
friends concern and the house will know
that health is a devolved matter for the
labor-run government in Wales where one
in five people Mr Speaker in the entire
country of Wales are now on a waiting
list so the government there should
focus on the people's priorities and
start cutting waiting lists as we are
doing here in England
holidays
thank you Mr Speaker
um a recent survey I did in Edinburgh
West showed that a heartbreaking 80 8-0
percent of those who responded said the
high cost of energy meant they would
have to ration it though I do not
represent a deprived area of the country
and almost a quarter of Scottish homes
now live in fuel poverty not helped of
course by the total absence of an
insulation program by the Scottish
government so will the prime minister
with no except that to allow the price
cap to rise will only make things worse
for millions of families and given the
significant reduction in the costs of
wholesale energy will he accept that
it's now time to listen to the liberal
Democrats
uh
Mr Mr Speaker is the the liberal
Democrat Shadow uh Energy Secretary who
who who said that there was no role for
nuclear power in our future energy
industry is not something that we need
to listen to but whether with regard
with regard to supporting people with
energy bills as I said earlier because
of the energy price guarantee we're
paying typically around half of a
family's Energy bill at the moment
that's worth a thousand pounds at the
moment but the support doesn't under and
there Mr Speaker over this next year
there will be around 1 000 pounds of
direct support to the most vulnerable
families Across the Nation with their
energy bills and with regard to Energy
Efficiency I agree with her it is
important which is why this government
has allocated over 6 billion pounds over
this Parliament and the new schemes that
we've just put in place will help
hundreds of thousands of households
across the country saving them around
300 pounds on their bills through
improvements for their Energy Efficiency
and you're right it should be available
everywhere including in Scotland Alberta
Costa to Mr Speaker as chairman of the
all party group for Greece can I put on
record how sad we all are for the tragic
train accident that's happened in
Grayson for the tragic loss of life
Mr Speaker double child rapist and
killer Colin Pitchfork is once again up
for parole next month now no the Prime
Minister doesn't have any
decision-making process in terms of the
independent parole board but can he
organize an urgent meeting with the
Secretary of State for justice so I can
refer my constituents views about this
dangerous man and he can take that into
account in his submissions to the
independent parole board
well Mr Speaker pitchfork's crimes were
heinous and our thoughts remain with
Linda and Dawn's friends and family my
honorable friend knows that it is for
the problem to determine these decisions
but my audible friend the Deputy Prime
Minister will be submitting his views on
the Pitchfork case to the parole ball
before the oral hearing is happy to meet
with the honorable gentleman again and
we have also recently published a root
and Branch review of the parole board
system which outlined our plans to
introduce greater ministerial oversight
and I look forward to having the
contributions and thoughts on that from
my honorable friend thank you Mr Speaker
today new figures showed that there's
been a 26 percent increase in people
sleeping rough meanwhile a conservative
part of party donor spent 25
000 pounds on a crystal encrusted
portrait of the Prime Minister and
another paid 40 000 pounds for for a
shooting trip
wow doesn't this show just how out of
touch the conservative party is on the
cost of living crisis
well Mr Speaker rough sleeping levels
rough sleeping levels are actually 35
percent lower in this past year compared
to the peak we as partly as a result of
the two billion pounds of extra
investment that we've made over these
three years to tackle rough sleeping and
we continue to have one of the lowest
rates of raw sleeping in the world uh
globally when last measure but we'll
continue to do more Mrs Leeper we don't
want anyone to have to sleep rough and
because of the innovations that we have
made we're taking more and more people
off the streets and the government will
keep delivering more James Sunderland
Mr Speaker last month the Pines Primary
School in bracknell achieved a good
rating in its ofsted inspection that in
itself is laudable what's significant is
that the Pines is now the 40th of 40
eligible schools in bracknell to be
great at good or outstanding Mr Speaker
This Clean Sweep is an outstanding
achievement and I'm very proud of
everyone locally so with the Prime
Minister please join with me in
congratulating our fantastic teachers
staff Governors and pupils and also
councilor Gareth Barnard and the entire
Education team at conservative run
ratnall forest Council
well Mr Mr Speaker
education is the closest thing we have
to a silver bullet for transforming
people's lives so I'm delighted to join
The Honorable friend in praising
everyone involved from the counselor to
the teachers to the staff to the
governors for delivering such fantastic
results they are in the business of
providing tremendous opportunity for the
children under their care and we all owe
them an enormous data gratitude okay
sell more thank you Mr Speaker citizens
advice estimate the number of households
unable to afford their energy bills will
double from one in ten to one in five
from April labor Mr Speaker has a plan
to help struggling families right across
the country now why can't the Prime
Minister see the need to take action
energy bills now avoid the cliff Edge
and they can shout all they like Mr
Speaker and stop plunging more people
into poverty from April
Mr Speaker we are helping people now
we're helping people with energy price
guarantee that is ensuring that there is
a thousand pound saving on their energy
bills right now and Mr Speaker we're
providing further Support over the
coming year for the most vulnerable with
direct cost of living support worth up
to a thousand pounds but also a record
increase in pensions record or increase
in benefits and a record increase in the
National living wage because that's what
a conservative government does
[Music]
[Applause]
businesses or smes which has meant
they've not received the level of
support that many other energy intensive
sectors have so will my writing or
friend look at what more support
particularly financial support can be
offered to help this sector to
decarbonize and invest in Energy
Efficiency measures
[Applause]
[Music]
well I uh I know my honorable friend is
a powerful advocate for his Ceramics
industry and rightly so it's been a
pleasure to meet with him and his
businesses in the past he'll know that
our Energy bill discount team does
support businesses with their energy
bills true to March of next year and
there are a range of other funds we have
to support energy intensive Industries
the scheme that he mentioned but also
the industrial energy transformation
fund which provides Capital grants to
businesses like his to help them
decarbonize and I look forward to
discussing this with him and his
businesses in the near future trick Ray
dude thank you Mr Speaker it's been
announced that on the me according
to Windsor Castle comprised of some of
the UK's keenest Community choirs and
amateur singers such as Refugee choirs
NHS choirs lgbtq plus singing groups and
deaf signing choirs
refugees taking part in that choir have
arrived here on small boats are from a
safe Third Country should they be
deported to Rwanda before or after they
sign for the king
[Music]
I mean it's Mr Speaker is amazing it is
amazing when previously we have had a
question about the awful tragedy of
illegal migration that happened just
recently that The Honorable gentleman
can't accept can't accept that it is in
fact there is nothing there is
absolutely nothing compassionate about
tolerating a legal migration when people
are dying okay
that's why this government will bring
forward legislation to improve the
system here and it's absolutely right
that if people come here illegally they
should be back sent to a safe
alternative because that is the only way
we will break the cycle of these
criminal gangs and stop people dying
needlessly
[Applause]
turn the heating off yeah this school
and others are spending money on psh E
materials by organizations such as
Stonewall and jigsaw that are educating
our boys and girls that they may not
have been born in the right body or have
an indigender identity would the PM meet
with me to see how we can stop this
unscientific ideological education being
taught in our schools and gets our
children learning what they should be
learning in a warm safe place oh Mr
Speaker we have boosted school funding
by around 2 billion pounds in each of
the next two years which will help
schools manage their energy costs but we
do expect schools to take responsible
and sensible decisions on their rhse
materials and making sure that those
materials are age appropriate suitable
politically impartial and value for
money I look forward to discussing this
with him in the future and I will assure
that he gets a meeting with the relevant
Minister final question Rosie Duffield
thank you
thank you Mr Speaker the Prime Minister
may be aware of Sky news's investigation
and report today on the over-the-counter
sales of nitrous oxide or laughing gas
to children and young teenagers one
alarming aspect is the change in the
size of canisters from 8 grams to 620
grams and ambulance call outs related to
overuse of tripled instead of
criminalizing the young people who buy
nitrous oxide isn't it time to take
urgent action against those knowingly
selling this harmful and potentially
life-changing substance to Children
underage
Thank The Honorable lady for her
question I share her concern and the
concerning members across the house
about nitrous oxide's detrimental impact
on communities it's contributional to
anti-social behavior and indeed I
mentioned it in the speech I made at the
beginning of this year specifically The
Advisory Council on the misuse of drugs
is conducting a review of nitrous oxide
and is looking particularly at this
question the Home Secretary has asked
them to expedite their review and we
will consider their advice carefully
when it is received that complete prime
minister's questions
well a surprise question there right at
the end about our Sky News investigation
that we are running today about the
availability of nitrous oxides to
youngsters from the labor MP Rosie
Duffield the Prime Minister there
confirming that a there is a count an
advisory Council on the masses of drug
which is looking at it he said that it's
going to be expedited and that the
government will look very closely at
their report let's just quickly talk to
our political Elizabeth Rigby about
prime minister's questions before we get
into this urgent question Beth kirstama
once again going on cost of living
focusing on that absolutely I mean I
think there's a couple things that what
we saw there was definitely a prime
minister with a with a spring in his
step he's had a few really rough prime
minister's questions of late and he
could at least go into the chamber today
knowing that there wasn't another
division over his brexit bill and and
feeling that he had landed that and I
think he was more confident today for
Kia stammer he just swerved on that and
went straight onto the cost of living